if you look at the products and services
that exist in this world sometimes it is
truly staggering the the number of
choices that people are given there is
this feeling again amongst people that I
spoke to who who are known champions of
simplicity that too much choice can
actually stifle a customer's enthusiasm
or or stall the the selling process
because you're just giving them too much
to think about so I just do my own
casual research and because I'm a techy
kind of a guy I look at like Dells
website versus HP's and then apples and
it's it is quite extraordinary if you
look at at Dells website they're making
these numbers slightly wrong I'm pretty
sure I'm right
26 distinct models of laptops this was
as a couple of months ago and I last
looked HP has 41 I believe it is and
Apple has three and what's extraordinary
is that if you look at the PC category
you know share of market Apple never
gets more than like 10% but because they
do these fewer things better their share
of the profit in the category is
actually more than HP and Dell combined
so that lack of choice isn't really
hurting Apple at all you might even say
it's helping them you don't want to dumb
things down and you don't want to get
people to feel like they don't have
enough choice but but you want to give
them the right choices as opposed to
infinite choices you want to make it
easier for them simpler so I think Apple
has done a terrific job of that and
there are other companies on in the
world that that treat their customers in
that way where it's a actually a way of
giving a customer more respect and
demonstrating that you understand what
drives them because you're not saying we
don't know what you want so here's 40
things to choose from
we're saying we get that you have this
particular need and this is a great
solution for you and that proves to
customers that you share their value
and when a person feels that a company
shares their values they tend to give
them their business and that makes them
more loyal customers there's a lot of
concern out there for Apple these days
that maybe it's losing its sense of
simplicity Steve Jobs is gone and Tim
Cook doesn't share those same values
whatever that product lines are getting
bigger and it's less simple to choose
what you're looking for product naming
could be an issue now this is where I'm
gonna start sounding if I haven't
already like an Apple fanboy and I don't
mean to because I try to be objective
but I think a lot of it is the result of
Apple just being the most over analysed
company on earth because if you look at
what they're doing compared to what
other companies are doing it is vastly
simpler I think what the real issue is
is that audiences mature Apple has tens
of millions more customers today than it
did when Steve Jobs was CEO and they're
just there's a wide range of needs
people say Steve would never do that
with certain things when in fact Steve
did do that the iPod was this revolution
changed the way we we listen to and
discover music and it was a super big
hit and then a couple of years later
there for iPods and nobody had any
problem with that because that was Steve
Jobs doing it so now we had a tremendous
hit of an iPhone and now there are three
models of iPhones you know they still
got one more to go before it's as bad as
iPod was but the reason they had all
those iPods and the reason they have all
these iPhones is because each one is
four distinctly different needs so to me
that's not a sign of complexity that's
just a company maturing having a larger
audience and and and maturing a
particular product line the same is true
of iPads you've got the pro version for
people who need to create you know with
the pencil and you've got more of a
consumer level iPad so those things
don't bother me at all naming is a
different issue because you get like an
iPhone there's a success and a 6s plus
and an S ee that doesn't
a number on it what's gonna happen when
the seven comes out is it still an se or
is it gonna be a seven se and why does
it have two letters and the other ones
have one letter and that kind of a thing
it does start feeling a little bit like
like many companies out there big
companies a lot of numbers and letters
and that part does not make me happy as
just as a as an Apple fan I think must
be a better way to do that you know
could be just like iPad or iMac and not
have any number attached to it and just
it has a year in parentheses when they
speak about it when you get serviced or
whatever you maybe you just have an
iPhone or an iPhone plus that sounds
simpler to me but you know Who am I
there's all kinds of behind the scenes
reasons why things happen but I think
again whether or not something is truly
simple almost doesn't matter it's the
perception of simplicity and I think
today the perception of simplicity with
Apple is a bit more challenged there are
those product issues which may or may
not be an issue depending on your point
of view but then there's something like
Apple music that has been generally not
well received when it comes to the
interface it's a it's confusing and you
do have to wonder how did Apple ever
release that product you know why didn't
they look at that and they have their
super high level of their high standards
when it comes to simplicity who didn't
raise their hand and say I don't get it
can you make that more clear so I don't
know I don't know the answer is there I
just think it's um maybe some growing
pains maybe Apple needs a minister of
simplicity to oversee it all who knows
but I don't think that Apple is losing
its love of simplicity if you listen to
anything Jim Cook says anything Johnny
I've says they're not just saying things
to try to fool us that's what they talk
about making products that people can
love and you have to have a simple
product for someone to fall in love with
it so there's no doubt in my mind they
have the values then you do execute on
the values but I think
though again the fanboy speaks I think
they'll be okay